ما في سيره لمحبي كره القدم في العالم امس
الا مباراه مانشستر يونايتد وليفربول
واللي انتهت سبعه صفر لصالح ليفربول
المباراه من قبل ما تبدا والانظار متجهله
يعني بتجمع نتيجه كبار والتوقعات كانت
منوعه لكن ما احد ابدا اتوقع هذه النتيجه
المذله بكل صراحه لمان يونايتد فالفريق من
سنه
31/1931 ما خسر اي مباراه بهذه النتيجه
واخر مره ليفربول دخلوا في مرمى 7 اهداف
كان في
1895 يعني من 128 سنه وقتها خلصت النتيجه
سبعه واحد لكن امس سبعه صفر يعني حتى شرف
انهم يدخلو هدف واحد المساكين ما قدروا
عليه فدخل في مرماهم هدف في الشوط الاول
وسته في الشوط الثاني وما انهم كانوا
رايحين يلاعبوا ليفربول في ارضه بكل ثقه
يعني الجماعه لهم 11 مباراه متتاليه ما
خسروا الاسبوع اللي فات جايبين كاس
الرابطه واللي كان اول لقب للنادي بال
2017 ويعني الامل كانت معلقه يعني كده
والمعنويات عاليه ليفربول حطمها كلها
الامل والمعنويات يعني بس اللي غير متوقع
في المباراه التاريخيه هذه انه يكون
رونالدو هو نجم التعليقات بعد المباراه
رونالدو اللي خلاص بيلعب في النصر ولا له
علاقه
بليفربول ليش تعالوا اذكركم رونالدو يعني
كان اول لاعب تحقق مع نجاحات مبهره بعدين
ننتقل راح ريال مدريد كمان حقق انجازات مو
طبيعيه منا رحل يوفنتوس وبعد يوفنتوس رجع
لمانشستر يونايتد لكن الرجعه ما كانت زي
اول مره واخر فتره قبل ما يترك عانه كثير
في النادي خاصه من مدربو اريكتين اللي قعد
او قعد رونالدو على مقاعد الاحتياط اخر
فتره وهاجموا اكثر من مره في تصريحات
اخرها كان قبل المباراه هذه على طول وفيها
انسال عن شعور واتجاه قراره بعدم التجديد
لرونالدو وقال انه الفريق ما كان في
انضباط وقت وجود رونالدو وانه مولدمان على
شيء وبينام ليله وهو مرتاح وما بيقلق لما
خلصت المباراه وانضرب مانشستر يونايتد
بالسبعه
انهالت التعليقات والبوستات من كل جهه
وبكل اللغات وفي غالبيتها شماته مو طبيعيه
وبالطبع ابرز الشامتين كانوا محبي رونالدو
اللي اساسا لا بيشجعوا مانشستر يونايتد
ولا حتى ليفربول واكتار شافوا في الموضوع
انتقام من مانشستر يونايتد انه مو بس يخزر
بنتيجه مخجله ولكن كمان يكون عدد الاهداف
سبعه وهو رقم رونالدو الشهير
في ناس مكتفت بالصور والتعليقات واحتجت
فيديوهات عشان تشتري غليلهم تخيلوا فيها
رده فعل رونالدو على النتيجه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
خالص
والدنيا
اجمد كده لا لا بص ما تعيطش مش عايزك كده
اجمد
[موسيقى]
ايه
ايه سبعه نلعب فين نلعب مع الدحين
سامعه يا جماعه
من ابرز المحبين والمدافعين عن رونالدو
الاعلامي البريطاني الشهير بيرس مورجان
وهذا عاد جنه حساباته لنصره رونالدو فعليا
كميه تغريدات تريد تويتر وتعليقات غير
طبيعيه ابرزها كان صوره لصحيفه او تصريح
مدرب مان يونايتد عن النوم ورونالدو وقال
له انه ان شاء الله تنام كويس اليوم يا
عبقري نشر كمان صوره
رونالدو من ظاهره مع الرقم 7 ونشر صوره
ثانيه هو شخصيا مع رونالدو من لقائهم اخير
سواء واللي فجر في رونالدو كثير قنابل
وتسبب حتى وقتها في خروجه من مان يونايتد
وعلق عليها وقال هذا الشيء المضحك اللي
اسمه كارما ونشر كمان من كم ساعه صوره
لمدرب مانشستر يونايتد وسائل الاستقلال
ولا لا وكيف ممكن يكمل بعد النتيجه
الكارثيه هذه على فكره عمل كمان روتويت
لفيديو لجماهير ليفربول في المباراه وفيها
كانوا بيهتفوا باسم رونالدو للسخريه من
مدرب خصمهم في المباراه مانشستر يونايتد
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]